[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 9 septembre très
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
sur tv 78 voici les titres de ce journal
c'est la rentrée pour les quelques 20
mille étudiants de l'université
versailles saint quentin dans ce journal
focus notamment sur le coût de la vie
alors qu'un récent classement place et
guyancourt en quatrième position et des
villes étudiantes les plus chères de
france et nous vous parlions la semaine
dernière de cette nouveauté de la
rentrée l'ile-de-france a équipé la
moitié de ces lycéens de tablettes
numériques ils sont 330 établissements
au total en bénéficier dont le lycée
dumont-d'urville à maurepas à vendredi
la présidente de la région valérie
pécresse était sur place
et puis samedi prochain c'est la 19e
journée mondiale des premiers secours
les bénévoles de la croix rouge se
mobilisent pour initier aux gestes qui
sauvent invité d'un martin de la barre
et cédric robin de la délégation
territoriale des yvelines à suivre aussi
dans ce journal ce qu'il faut retenir du
week-end sportif dans le département
mais l'actualité du jour donc et aussi
de cette semaine c'est le retour sur les
bancs des amphithéâtres des quelques 20
mille étudiants de l'ue vs qu rentrée
qui a démarré dès la semaine dernière et
qui se s'intensifie toute cette semaine
on en parle de cette rentrée avec vous
naim chili bonsoir ans à représentant de
l'union des étudiants et des yvelines
vous êtes l'ancien président de l'unef à
l'université versailles saint quentin
une section de l'unef que vous avez
décidé avec ses membres de quitter aussi
de dissoudre cette section pourquoi ce
choix
même à ce choix parce que aujourd'hui on
comptait on vient contexte assez
particulier
en deux ans il a jamais été aussi facile
pour un gouvernement d'attaqué droits
des jeunes c'est la mise en place de la
section entre l'université et la hausse
des frais d'inscription 3000 laurent
licence 4000 euros en master pour les
sillons à l'étranger ou encore la baisse
rappelle tout ça sans qu'un mouvement
étudiant arrive a empêché ces réformes
notamment parce que l'unef qui était en
mission dont j'ai fait partie et qui a
été historiquement l'ordination phare du
mouvement étudiant a pas été en capacité
de mettre en place une vraie stratégie
pour coordonner le mouvement étudiant et
mettre en place c'est finalement un
rapport de force pour battre le
gouvernement prise de position du coup
pas assez importante qui est aussi
peut-être le nom soutient un autre
mouvement alors qu'ils étaient en dehors
des étudiants la base c'est le mouvement
des gilet jaune
peut-être aussi cette raison aussi
en fait oui ce qu'on constate c'est que
depuis le début du quinquennat on a une
f qui a ca spectatrice qui commente
l'actualité mais qu'un fuit pas vraiment
sur le réel notamment sur l'action des
jeunes qui portaient un bon nombre des
revendication que les lycéens qui ont
bloqué le lycée en décembre six portes
et que nous aussi on aurait pu porter
par exemple dans lequel on sait pas
forcément investi et de ce conte ce
constat là et dont on a tiré une
conclusion le fait qu'ils ont acheté
plus l'outil le mieux à même pour mener
nos batailles c'est pour ça que nous
mais aussi tout un tas d'autres sections
qu'elle porte ce qu'en france on a
décidé de la quitter
donc il y avait plus de prises de
positions concrètes du coup quid de
votre présentation sein du conseil
d'administration de l'ubs est ce que
l'unef avait une place au sein de ce
conseil d'administration est ce que elle
va perdurer pour pour les organisations
étudiantes elles valent perdure est
maintenant de la nouvelle organisation a
nouvellement créé puisque c'est
l'ensemble de la section locale qui a
quitté l'unef à versailles saint quentin
et aussi parce qu'au moment où nos élus
avaient été élus au sein du conseil
nistration ou s'ils ont déjà en rupture
avec la direction de l'unef à l'époque
ça si donc déjà donc nos prises de
position qui était porte au sein de
penser avant de passer à autre chose
qu'est ce que ça change du coup
concrètement que vous deviez aujourd'hui
l'union des étudiants des yvelines ça
change tout un tas de choses c'est déjà
on est sorti un peu des contraintes qui
nous impose l unef au niveau national et
aussi nous ce qu'on essaye de faire
cesser les engage dans un processus de
regroupement de toutes les forces
syndicales qui il s'endort de l'unef
aujourd'hui en france nous tout un tas
incertaine des sections locales sont
quittés l'unef on a déposé une liste au
cneser qui est l'instance représentative
de l'enseignement supérieur on a obtenu
deux élus soit autant que l'unef ce qui
montre que quand on s'allie avec
l'ensemble des forces syndicales dans ce
pays hôte l'unef on peut avoir un
véritable rapport de force pour mener la
bataille face au gouvernement
on va parler de vos combats de cette
année en cette année universitaire peut
être l'un de ses combats c'est
l'amélioration de la vie étudiante votre
ancien syndicat l'unef a sorti fin août
son étude sur le coût de la vie
étudiante ce qu'il en ressort c'est que
guyancourt serait la quatrième ville
étudiante la plus chère de france
dépense moyenne mensuelle est de 1000 66
euros et 65 centièmes on constate aussi
en dans ce classement si vous le
regardez
que ce sont les villes franciliennes 1
qui dominent ce palmarès la première en
province et nice qui arrive en dixième
position
on précise juste les conditions de ce
classement il prend en compte est les
frais d'inscription de restauration de
logement et de transport étudier et
vivre en même temps en ile-de-france
nenshi lit ça devient de plus en plus
difficile oui ça a été déjà beaucoup
auparavant on a qu'à voir ce classement
mais ça l'est encore dans cette année
avec lui une augmentation à tous les
niveaux par exemple en ligne versailles
c'est + 3 5 % d'augmentation dans le
logement
c'est aussi dans le public par exemple
se nourrir les cafétérias ducrocq ceux
qui ont vu leur tarif augmenter
également
bref ce initiation où tout augmente
actuellement et là-dessus
malheureusement bien peu de choses sont
faites souvent dans les yvelines les
villes ministère m de se vanter dans
leur communication qu'elle possède des
sites universitaires dans leur sein mais
par contre qu'il s'agit de mettre de
véritables politiques en faveur des
scissions édifiante et un peu moins de
choses qui sont faites par rapport à ça
et c'est ce qui explique aujourd'hui un
tel tableau et un tel bilan qui est fait
gérer son budget un point un étudiant
peut s'apparenter un casse tête comment
il gère justement ces étudiants du
véhicule leur budget marilyn iapichino
et margot du roi sont allés leur poser
la question ce matin je pense que c'est
environ 400 euros par mois pour les
sorties pour manger tout ça et 4 euros
pour le logement
j'habite dans le sud et je suis venu
faire mes études ici et du coup j'ai un
appart
j'ai une heure et demie transport aligne
à réunir autour le loyer d'abord le
premier la première de dépense après la
nourriture
et puis après tout les sorties ça va
assez vite donc donc on réduit les
sorties pour moi à payer le loyer
restant du c3 0,25 et après
quand je mange chez moi je la mange
projet pour 2 0 c'est pour ça qu'on fait
des études de sciences avait espéré
pouvoir dément avoir un job qui nous
permet de vivre un peu mieux je suis en
alternance du coup
bah c'est de l'argent de poche enfin que
je mets de côté mais ça me permet de
subvenir à mes dépenses essence péage
j'ai pas le choix je trouve que
l'alternance est le bon moyen pour t'en
sortir ce que boursière ça sert à rien
tu vis pas tu survis quoi tu fous que tu
souhaitais papa maman derrière ou alors
tu prends un café à côté mais t'es pas à
fond dans tes études enfin vie
parisienne les étudiants de ces
chercheurs une réaction des millions
sont entre les dépenses de transport de
logement de restauration c'était
vraiment un casse tête aujourd'hui de
gérer son budget chaque mois da c'est un
vrai casse tête et surtout on se rend
compte qu'il ya pas beaucoup de
solutions soit on dépend de nos parents
nous ont dit qu'on vit chez nos parents
on a un temps de transport assez
important à faire chaque matin et puis
même pour son autonomie pour son
émancipation c'est assez compliqué soit
on travaille son conseil que salar
étudiants c'est la première cause
d'échec à l'université s'élancera donc
en fait d'un ce casse tête mais il met
en jeu nos études et nous poursuite à
l'université et c'est là aussi ce qui
était dit assez intéressant c'est que le
niveau des bourses et pas assez élevé
aujourd'hui et que le nombre de têtes à
destination des étudiants est
aujourd'hui insuffisante pour répondre
au budget que l'on doit dépenser à
chaque mois ici qu'est ce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui il faut se mettre tous
autour d'une table universités syndicats
pour aussi les organismes étudiants les
organismes qui peuvent aider les
étudiants à se loger pour trouver des
solutions dans les solutions les connaît
il faut du courage pour eclipse pour la
mettre en place
donc nous comprendre c'est que
l'ensemble des universitaires nuit en
cours mais aussi versailles bézy
rambouillet bref toutes les vieilles qui
possède des sites de l'unesco devrait
mettre en place par exemple un
encadrement des loyers pour diminuer la
hausse des loyers pour mettront pas et
demi-tarif dans les transports en commun
le val de marne par exemple est une
collectivité qui met en place des
réductions sur pass navigo des
collectivités pourraient le faire eux
aussi
et puis aussi c'est des choses que le
véhicule pourrait faire par exemple les
femmes on l'a pas évoqué un budget
supérieur à celui des hommes de par
certaines dépenses comme les protections
périodiques bien non pense que
l'université et le crous pourra mettre
en place des distributeurs de
protections périodiques gratuit en libre
service d'écouté présent levé excuse à
ce propos il s'engage en tout cas à
trouver des solutions l'interrogeaient à
la conférence des présidents
d'université c'est une réalité
de pareils sa région parisienne après je
pense qu'il faut regarder dans le
contexte la plus chère mais dans quelles
conditions et donc voilà on va prendra
en compte évidemment
je crois qu'on a des structures
universitaires avec le crous du logement
afin de pouvoir déjà avoir de la place
accueillir dans les meilleures
conditions possible de comprendre enfin
le nécessaire pour que
les étudiants soient accueillis dans
notre territoire de la meilleure façon
possible et avec des facilités de
logement et à des prix tout à fait
raisonnable l'un le budget le président
de l'université versailles saint quentin
sur cette thématique du coût de la vie
étudiante qui en tout cas une solution
qui ressortit ces derniers jours c'est
gabriel attal qui est secrétaire d'état
qui a parlé d' instaurer alors ça c'est
pour les étudiants qui travaillent une
prime d'activité pour ces étudiants qui
travaillent afin voilà de d'augmenter
leur pouvoir d'achat chaque mois est ce
que c'est une bonne décision ça pourrait
être une bonne décision qui pourrait se
mettre en place
on se rend compte que c'est des
propositions de personnes qui ne savent
pas ce que c'est l'arrêté de la ville
quand il vient alors oui dans l'absolu
c'est une bonne chose qu en fait le
problème c'est pas est-ce qu'on permet
aux étudiants salariés de mieux vivre
c'est ce qu'on permet aussi au soleil de
ne pas à ses salariés tout court est de
pouvoir passer de leur temps dans leurs
amphis plutôt que derrière une caisse à
mcdo par exemple donc si le gouvernement
de l'argent pour il ne l'est pas dans
les bourses
par exemple qui est un moyen qui s'est
déjà aujourd'hui et je joue bien un
élément tout à l'heure c'est la
sélection d'histoires étranges et qui
aujourd'hui ont vu leurs frais
d'inscription augmenté mais aussi tout
un tas de dépenses qui fait que des fois
sur l'accès au logement ils ont plus de
difficultés là encore je pense est un
sujet sur lequel lui véhiculés sur les
collectivités locales devraient avancer
pour migrer denise de vie un dernier mot
très rapide en 30 secondes on est déjà
la fin de cet entretien les autres
combats les autres points de vigilance
en cette rentrée pour l'union des
étudiants des villes ils sont nombreux
de par les attaques du gouvernement
sélection de la réforme des retraites on
sait qu'elle va concerner aussi en
priorité les jeunes la question des
grèves pour climat il ya une première
date le 21 septembre
on va participer à ses organes à ces
manifestations et 11 en assemblée
générale sur l'université et enfin
dernier élément la question des tarifs
en restauration puisque le crous a
annoncé on les disait 3,025 et tout à
l'heure le cros annoncé que cela elle
augmente et donc du conte mènera la
bataille sur cela merci d'être passé en
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
représentant de l'union des étudiants
des yvelines elle nouveautés justement
de la rentrée mais dans les lycées cette
fois ci la moitié des élèves franciliens
bénéficie d'une tablette numérique
gratuite pour étudier la présidente de
la région valérie pécresse s'est rendue
vendredi au lycée dumont-d'urville à
maurepas pour présenter ce dispositif
aurait les onze étaient sur place
découverte pour ces élèves de première
de leur nouvel outil de travail
le lycée dumont-d'urville à maurepas
fait partie des 3 130 établissements
franciliens a opté cette année pour le
numérique
la tablette au lycée c'est beaucoup plus
que des manuels scolaires c'est
évidemment 9 manuels scolaires en
seconde cette manuel en première mais
c'est aussi un espace numérique de
travail à laboratoire de langues
intégrer un site pour découvrir des
stages ainsi d'orientation un site aussi
pour avoir d'autres ressources
pédagogiques vidéo audio
ces tablettes sont confiés gratuitement
aux élèves durant leur scolarité dans le
secondaire
objectif que chacun soit sur un même
pied d'égalité en matière de numérique
je trouve ça génial le principe d'avoir
une tablette de remplacer toutes celles
où toute cette lourdeur qu'on pouvait
avoir dans le sac et ça pourra nous
permettre de plus avancées au niveau du
système scolaire
ce dispositif représente pour la région
un investissement de 150 millions
d'euros sur trois ans particularité le
moteur de recherche ainsi que la
tablette sont 100% français j'avais le
choix entre un fabricant américain bien
connu avec une pomme est une société
française une start up française qui
assume j'ai choisi la tablette française
parce que si la région capitale ne
choisit pas la technologie française qui
le fera au total en ile-de-france 160000
tablettes vont être distribués dans les
lycées ayant opté pour le numérique et
lors de sa visite valérie pécresse a
également remis un chèque d'un million
d'euros maire de maurepas grégory gary
astier ce financement accordé au titre
du contrat d'aménagement régional avait
été voté le 19 mars dernier
cette subvention a servi à la
réhabilitation et à l'extension du
groupe scolaire delajoux et servira
aussi aux travaux être d'aménagement du
centre-ville de maurepas vendredi
toujours six députés la république en
marche et modem des yvelines était à
montigny le bretonneux elles ont visité
les locaux de la caisse nationale de
l'assurance vieillesse
au programme rencontre avec la
directrice régionale pour parler du
système actuel mais aussi de la réforme
des retraites sur laquelle planchent
actuellement le gouvernement le
reportage de nicolas landry découvrir
ses droits à la retraite à partir du
service en ligne assez l'exercice
proposé au député yvelinois par la
caisse nationale 2
assurance vieillesse de montigny le
bretonneux c'est mission
l'accompagnement des futurs retraités
par rapport à leurs droits et le
paiement des pensions
bien évidemment les retraités n'ont pas
à s'inquiéter c'est déjà fait voilà donc
là les droits sont acquis la pension est
acquise les futurs retraités se pose des
questions effectivement là pour
l'instant les rassure c'est à dire c'est
la réglementation constante ceux qui
veulent partir partent
et c'est peut-être les plus jeunes en
fait pour lequel l'enjeu et est
véritablement les concernent
cette visite des parlementaires lrm et
modem un moment de préparation des
travaux autour de la réforme des
retraites actuellement en concertation
après la remise du rapport de jean paul
delevoye alors ambassadrice des
retraites s'est déjà présentée aux
citoyennes et aux citoyens les
réflexions que nous avons conduite avec
le haut commissaire qui a été nommé donc
jean paul delevoye qui vient de
rejoindre l'exécutif
ce qui est intéressant dans la réforme
de leveaux a c'est finalement de dire si
une réforme qui est globale on
transforme le système en profondeur on
fonctionne sur la base d'un régime à
points on simplifie ya plus de régimes
spéciaux je pense qu'il ya pas de totem
ce qu'il faut c'est prendre le temps de
la consultation avec les partenaires
sociaux
et puis surtout de dire que c'est une
réforme globale qui permettra de
garantir à tous les français quel que
soit leur âge aujourd'hui qu'ils
toucheront une retraite à la fin leur
carte professionnelle
prise en compte de l'âge ou des
trimestres de cotisation pour le départ
à la retraite c'est l'une des
interrogations de cette réforme dans les
yvelines en 2018 l'âge moyen des départs
à la retraite
atteignez 63 ans politique locale avec
cette alliance en vue des municipales
2020 à voisins le bretonneux olivier à
fond saut et thiery gastaud tous deux
conseillers d'opposition feront liste
commune pour le scrutin
ils l'ont annoncé samedi lors d'une
conférence de presse les détails avec ce
sujet de mélanie poquet de mathilde de
2min une alliance pour les municipales
2020 à voisins le bretonneux
c'est ce que souhaite olivier afonso et
thierry gastaud de conseillers
municipaux d'opposition de la commune
c'est vraiment une grande déception un
sentiment de gâchis pour tout vous dire
nous avons eu un maire
qui est vice président de l'agglo qui
conseillère départementale et donc sur
les sujets majeurs de notre ville à rien
n'a évolué la remise qui est ça fait
plus de dix ans je crois que c'est en
stand by la circulation rien n'a été
fait sur les six dernières années pour
cette liste qui se veut sans étiquette
les priorités sont fixées notamment ceux
qui concernent l'aménagement de la ville
si on mobilise nos partenaires
l'agglomération et le département et
qu'on s'inspire de tous les dossiers
tous les projets d'urbanisme qui ont été
rédigées les années précédentes les
solutions existent il faut investir
massivement faut être ambitieux mais la
solution n'existait pas du bricolage en
espérant sur des mêmes voies
qu'actuellement surpasser 30%
d'habitants supplémentaires c'est pas
possible
jointe par téléphone la maire sortante
de voisins-le-bretonneux élu depuis 2015
alexandra rosetti se dit surprise par
cette alliance entre deux représentants
de l'opposition qui est profond des
cantaliens a frappé fort mais bon il
reste quand même deux autres sont les
bienvenus un train il honte à fusionner
lors de votre relation avant demain
paieront volonté chez lui devant la
bienvenue parmi d'autres candidats
oui tout candidat alexandra rosetti qui
a donc annoncé sur notre antenne qu'elle
se représenterait pour les élections
municipales en 2020 le scrutin se
déroulera le week end du 15 et 22 mars
ce chiffre édifiant seuls 20 % des
français seraient capables de pratiquer
les gestes de premiers secours selon une
étude de la fédération française de
cardiologie
c'est pour informer et initier petits et
grands à ces gestes qui sauvent des vies
ac est organisée la journée mondiale des
premiers secours 19e édition au
programme ce samedi on en parle avec
vous martine de la barre et cédric robin
bonsoir sous deux de la délégation
territoriale des yvelines de la croix
rouge vous en êtes la présidente martine
de la barre et cédric aux robins
directeur pour l'urgence et le
secourisme c'est une journée spéciale
qui se déclinera au niveau local à
versailles avec une journée devant la
mairie de versailles les objectifs ils
sont clairs martin de la barre c'est de
faire connaître davantage ces gestes qui
sauvent alors ça va même au delà de ça
c'est là
la croix-rouge voudrait que chaque
personne chaque citoyen soit un petit
peu acteur dans la chaîne de l'urgence
et du secours c'est à dire que vous on
est tous confrontés on va tous être
confronté un jour à des situations
compliquées des situations
traumatisantes
et si nous nous sommes les témoins de
cette action qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
en attendant les secours en fait c'est
un peu tout ce passage là que nous
devons apprendre à l'ensemble de la
population
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour la
personne qui à côté de moi qui ne fera
sur dix est un proche c'est vraiment
gros temps de jeu fille souffre de
sauver des vies en attendant les
sauveteurs les sauveteurs sont pas
toujours là en cas d'inondation d'
incendies
ça va plus loin que le geste qui sont le
premier secours que nous pratiquons
évidemment et que nous et que nous nous
initions les personnes pour cela
absolument dans une thématique chaque
année cette année c'est les personnes
exclues exclu pardon il y aura un focus
auprès des des publics finalement les
plus éloignés à ces gestes de premiers
secours oui parce que finalement ça va
ça va avec ce que je vous ai dit
précédemment les personnes qui sont dans
la rue les personnes handicapées les
personnes âgées doivent pouvoir aussi
pratiqué le geste premier le réflexe
quel réflexe savoir quand elles se
trouvent en situation très très
compliqué donc tout le monde doit
apprendre à attendre les secours
qu'est ce que je fais en attendant les
secours et donc cette année le focus est
mis sur les personnes exclues les autres
chiffres l'inpes on estime que 6 20% de
français supplémentaires était formée au
secourisme dix mille vies pourraient
être sauvées en france alors je les
destine journée nationale qui se décline
au niveau local à versailles ce sera
samedi de 10h à 18h sur le parvis de la
mairie de versailles le programme
qu'elle est de le chambrer comme dire
que avery
il se trouve que c'est l'inauguration
pour la croix rouge française de cette
journée mondiale des premiers secours
qui avaient été initiés d'ailleurs par
la croix rouge française dont le
lancement de matthew c'est le lancement
national qui circulait seule à 10h à
versailles nous avons donc le notre
président national jean jacques avait
jam nous aurons préfet nous aurons pas
mal de personnalités parce que c'est une
journée importante
donc je voulais signaler après l'on ne
recevant le public toute la journée
entre 10h et 18h là maintenant les
caisses collecte de l'information on
imagine à ces gestes qui sauvent tout au
long de la journée c'est vrai que robin
du coup on aura plusieurs ateliers des
thématiques différentes notamment des
initiations aux premiers secours à
destination des enfants à partir de 10
ans des petites formations d'une heure à
prendre à des formations un peu plus
spécifique autrement capables à
destination des personnes d'un public
handicapé physiquement
voilà où on adapte un petit peu notre
type de formation on aura d une
formation sur la prévention des
accidents de la vie courante aussi en
escape game ou autre ère d'une maison
des dangers avec des énigmes à résoudre
tout au travers de différents ateliers
on aura un escape game aussi la maison
des dangers comment fuir tous ces
dangers autre ère de petites énigmes etc
etc
être fort mais aussi aux défibrillateurs
à leur utilisation qui sont présents à
ces défibrillateurs dans les enceintes
sportives
c'est aussi faire une formation donc
l'initiation aux premiers secours en
l'urgence cardiaque aussi où c'est
vraiment focalisé sur l'accident sur
l'arrêt cardiaque ou là on apprend à
utiliser un défibrillateur prévenir les
secours et mettre en place un massage
cardiaque et donc cette journée un
lancement national de cette journée
mondiale des premiers secours qui sera
fait à versailles une journée de 10h à
18h sur le parvis de la mairie
un dernier mot martin de la barre pour
terminer sur la croix rouge des yvelines
oui alors d'abord
si personne n'a pas pu venir se former
ce jour là vous trouverez notre site la
croix rouge des évidemment pour pouvoir
venir dans n'importe quelle unité locale
on vous faudra évidemment si vous n'avez
pas pu le faire là vous le ferez dans
nos unités locales et pratiquement 2000
bénévoles dans les yvelines et nos
bénévoles sont très compétents très fort
mais nous avons des actions sociales
nous faisons de l'urgence du secourisme
nous sommes extrêmement présent partout
sur le territoire des yvelines grâce à
tous les bénévoles qui travaillent là
elle vous l'avez dans toutes les
informations sur le site internet de la
délégation territoriale de la croix
rouge des yvelines merci c'est en
partant de là bas cette délégation a
territoriale de la croix rouge française
des yvelines lors du sport à présent sur
tv 78 et on va présenter l'ensemble des
résultats sportifs du week-end avec vous
nicolas dandrimont soir réservé gorille
et vous oui vous nous présenter ce qu'il
s'est passé sportivement sur le
territoire que du football pour ce
week-end parce que les seuls clubs à
avoir repris les championnats à l'aube
du mois de septembre
les clubs de football et on commence
avec ses images de nationale 2 pour le
compte de la 5e journée le fc mantois
affronter fleuri les yvelinoises se sont
inclinés sur leur terrain on vient de
voir une faute commise par les mantois
dans la surface de réparation donc un
penalty et puis on voit les mantois la
défense débordé par là les attaques des
essonniens
le score final 3-0 et de leur côté dans
la même poule poissy est allé chercher
un match nul sur le terrain du fc
lorient 2 2 sur les cinq premières
rencontres les pisciacais contre une
victoire deux nuls et deux défaites au
classement aucun yvelinois dans la
première partie du tableau on voit un un
championnat dominé par chartres il faut
aller dans la seconde partie du tableau
pour voir poissy qui pointe à la 11e
place alors que les mantois occupe la
dernière place du classement avec cinq
défaites en cinq matches
la nationale 2 vous avez aussi des
résultats de nationale 3 à nous proposer
effectivement grégory début de saison
royal pour versailles ils ont remporté
ce week-end le derby haut rhinois face
aux mureaux le score 3 0
au classement les versailles et occupe
la première place alors écoutez bien
quatre matches quatre victoires aucun
but encaissé mais ils ont fait trembler
les filets dix fois depuis le début de
la saison un bilan très positif on leur
souhaite de continuer on termine avec la
cette fois ci les divisions régionales
régionales de avec trappe et rap a
concédé sa deuxième défaite de la saison
en s'inclinant sur le terrain de poissy
2 mais soyons indulgents c'est seulement
leur deuxième match de la saison
au classement ils pointent à la dernière
place derrière champigny sur marne mais
seulement à cause du goal avérage
puisqu'ils ont tous les deux aucun point
et prochain rendez vous pour les 17
clubs yves binois c'est le week-end
prochain avec le 3e tour de la coupe de
france et deuxième match de la saison on
précise aussi que tu rappes monte de
division équipements donc se retrouve
dans un nouveau championnat avec des
équipes peut être un peu plus un peu
plus forme
voilà on vous retrouve nicolas merci
pour pour ce point on vous retrouve dans
le 7-8 sport dans quelques instants et
vous allez nous parler notamment d'une
expédition en bolivie dans le désert
bolivien après une aventure dans des
conditions extrêmes à la fois physique
et et climatiques dans le dessert le
désert pardon de sel bolivien
on va parler on n'aura pas le temps mais
malheureusement de parler du
semi-marathon de bois d'arcy on fera un
retour à demain dans ce journal avant de
vous quitter ce cet événement avec les
passionnés de motos et de voitures
anciennes
ancien qui se sont donné rendez-vous à
gambais ce week-end la sixième édition
de motors and soul se dérouler au
château de neuville hilarant seraient
rassemblés environ dix mille personnes
manon varaldo pour le reportage de la et
mustang chevrolet ou encore porsche pour
les voitures mais aussi triomphe indian
harley davidson pour les motos pour sa
sixième édition motors en sol s'est
déroulée au château de neuville à gan b
ou c une réunion de passionnés d'autos
et de motos caractère ça véhicules avec
lesquels
il ya une relation émotionnelle qui
s'instaure parce que il évoque un acteur
célèbre un film célèbre l'enfance
également à ses 12 ans ce passionné a eu
un flash
il a vu une ford mustang sur le circuit
de linas montlhéry
aujourd'hui il est collectionneur ça
c'est une ford mustang de 2,66 qui a été
récupéré dans les années 80 dans une
dans une casse et qui était et qui a été
détruite en fait et on est passé au bon
moment on a pu récupérer l'automobile
beaucoup de temps pour la pour la
restaurer
mais au bout de deux trois ans et demi
de dur labeur en quand même resserre
faire quelque chose d'assez sympathique
50 exposants étaient présents pour le
plaisir des mordus d'autos et de motos
anciennes
quand on est ici au motor and soul or ça
transpire la passion
il ya des véhicules de toutes les
époques qui a pratiquement sortent des
musées pour là ça fait plaisir de les
voir rouler plusieurs animations
proposées sur place balade concert
barbier mais aussi concours de style où
les participants sabic dans le style
vestimentaire de l'année de leur
véhicule à l'image de ce propriétaire
d'une delahaye 1935 venu pour la sixième
édition de moteurs henshall haut
montrer ma voiture avoir l'occasion de
la faire rouler aussi et 20 cadres
prestigieuse
la prochaine édition est déjà fixée elle
se tiendra le 5 et 6 septembre 2020
c'est la fin de ce journal belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]